chantal marcotte a une masse de 9
centimètres près des reins en temps
normal elle aurait été opérée la semaine
prochaine au centre hospitalier de
l'université de montréal continue clip
blocs opératoires seront fermées est
possible de faire l'opération pour le
moment si tout va bien ça va prendre
quatre à six semaines de nombreux jours
à vivre dans l'angoissé niant que ça tu
meurs potentiellement cancéreuses ne
grossisse davantage il s'attaque à
d'autres organes j'ai pensé que j'étais
un courjault compte tenu des
conséquences que cela peut avoir
j'ai l'impression que on mise tout sur
le court n'a point laisse tomber ce qui
a d'autres à côté elle fait partie des
nombreux passion mis de côté pour
s'assurer que le système de santé gagne
sa bataille contre le coronavirus
partout dans la province
des chirurgies considéré non urgentes
ont été reportées pour libérer des lits
d'hospitalisation et du personnel
médical
c'est pour ça qu'on fait ce délestage
temporaire et ça met pas à risque les
personnes c'est bien évaluer dans tous
les établissements des comités évaluent
15 opérations peuvent être reportés
quels patients devront attendre plus
longtemps que prévu
atteinte du cancer du sein hélène chabot
devait subir une mastectomie aujourd'hui
même
elle a été repoussée que j'avais dans
une partie est un droit qui est foyer
cancer donc un foyer dans ma tête c'est
quand même pas mal
donc si est ce que je me fasse opérer
pour la mastectomie complet après ses
insultes à de se propager des opérations
urgentes où le patient ne peut pas ne
peut pas attendre et vous continuez à
faire ces opérations là les opérations
qui ont été les chirurgies qui ont été
reportés c'est pour des cancers du sein
qui sont beaucoup moins agressif mais le
report de toutes ces opérations soulève
de nombreuses questions à plus long
terme ce qui nous inquiète aussi c'est
pour la préco vide alors qu'est ce qui
va arriver aux gens qu'on va décaler
arrive at il dit en avoir trop justement
et voit-on surcharger le système pour la
suite des choses
c'est une énorme opération de rattrapage
qui devra se mettre en branle ici
olivier cachin radio canada montréal